donc mesdames et messieurs je propose de
pouvoir commencer cette cette audition
comme vous le savez notre délégation
prépare un rapport très attendu sur la
continuité territoriale donc Catherine
Concorde en visioconférence avec
Guillaume chevrolier en présentiel sont
les rapporteurs engagés en janvier
dernier sur le dispositif applicable à
la engage des oui sur le dispositif
applicable à la Corse notre cycle
d'audition va s'avérer car nous
examinerons ce rapport le jeudi 30 mars
prochain outre les documents recueillis
nous avons pu mener une réunion plénière
une dizaine une dizaine d'auditions et
des tables rondes sur ce sujet majeur à
nos yeux nous avons notamment eu des
responsables de la Dom le 16 février
dernier avec un échange très
enrichissant dont la perspective de la
réforme de la Dom 2024 nos rapporteurs
se sont également rendus dernièrement en
Guyane et en Guadeloupe pour évaluer les
politiques appliquées sur place et les
contraintes dans lesquelles elle
s'inscrivent ils ont ainsi pu arriver à
tirer l'attention sur le double défi de
la continuité intérieure sur ces
territoires pour finaliser leurs
investigations nos audition ce matin les
représentants des ministères compétents
nous vous remercions évidemment de votre
présence nous accueillons donc
respectivement pour la direction
générale des Outre-mer à madame Isabelle
Richard je suis directrice des
politiques publiques et Marc dumelson
sous-directeur de l'évaluation de la
prospective et de la dépense de l'État
qui sont accompagnés de Monsieur Yves
mont chargé de mission économie
territoriale et économie du transport
aérien à la sous-direction des
politiques publiques monsieur Guillaume
vaille conseiller budget et finances
locales madame nousunabasque conserve
parlementaire du ministre délégué chargé
des outre-mer pour la Direction générale
de l'aviation civile des GRC donc
Monsieur Emmanuel vivait sous-directeur
des services aériens direction du
transport aérien et pour le ministère de
la santé et de la prévention messieurs
Timothée Mons directeur adjoint
guillaume-bouillard chef du bureau dans
la direction de financement du système
de soins de la DSS
et Monsieur Pierre Savary chef du bureau
de la DGOS mesdames messieurs vous allez
avoir la parole pour vous présenter
présenter en l'occurrence surtout vous
observations sur la base de la trame qui
vous a été communiquée par les la
délégation je vous laisserai et ensuite
surtout les rapporteurs intervenus pour
vous demander des précisions ainsi que
nos autres collègues qui sont en
présentiel et en distanciel qui je
l'espère j'en suis certain auront sans
doute beaucoup de questions à vous poser
madame sous directrice des politiques
publiques vous avez la parole
et effectivement
je j'aperçois sur l'écran un micro coupé
je vois le micro coupé sur notre écran à
gauche
Catherine est-ce que tu m'entends
désormais voilà donc en fait je viens
juste de terminer l'introduction donc tu
n'as pas rater grand chose
d'exceptionnel je te rassure
donc j'introduis
j'introduisais les débats et je donnais
la parole à ce directrice des politiques
publiques madame Isabelle Richard
monsieur monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs nous vous
remercions de
d'avoir convié les administrations pour
participer à ce à vos travaux sur le sur
la continuité territoriale
tout d'abord avant de prendre la trame
et que nous nous répondrons peut-être
nous répondrons avec mon collègue Marc
dem100 de concert mon collègue est en
charge de de des questions du budget et
de l'évaluation à la direction générale
des Outre-mer nous répondrons à vos
questions peut-être juste avant de
dérouler ce questionnaire vous dire
effectivement il y a sans doute pas
outre-mer une continuité territoriale
mais dès continuités territoriales avec
des publics et des modalités bien sûr
différentes comme vous l'avez comme vous
le comme vous le savez il y a ce que
l'on appelle l'aide de tout public
l'aide à la continuité territoriale mais
qui est en fait qui se concentre sur les
factures qui réservaient aux personnes
aux revenus modestes mais qui
représentent bien sûr l'essentiel de nos
de nos concitoyens
ultramarin
l'essentiel de nos concepts nos
concitoyens intramarins également les
passeports mobilité donc ils sont
réservés aux personnes en formation ou
qui viennent faire qui viennent faire
leurs études en métropole donc il est
vraiment évidemment essentiel pour ces
différents publics de de maintenir cette
offre de continuité territoriale de la
renforcer nous nous y employons nous y
employons régulièrement pour l'adapter
aux évolutions des besoins et aux
évolutions des contraintes des
contraintes extérieures je pense que la
première la dernière évolution que vous
souhaitiez effectivement abordé était
celle de la réforme de 2021 c'est la
première de vos questions qui portent
essentiellement sur la revalorisation du
bon de la continuité territoriale et
plus particulièrement une revalorisation
pour les collectivités du Pacifique
puisque là on a une première exemple
d'adaptation à la hausse des coûts du
transport qui a été réalisé en 2021 et
également d'autres
d'autres adaptations ont été réalisées
pour les drones notamment analysement
des tarifs c'est-à-dire que là il y a
une disparition du tarif simple qui
existait pour la continuité territoriale
et donc une alignement un aliment sur le
tarif majoré donc c'était une première
étape de renforcement de la prise en
charge de de
dépenses continuité territoriales et
puis également d'autres adaptations ont
été réalisées notamment pour élargir les
bénéficiaires de ce qu'on appelle la
continuité territoriale funéraire c'est
vrai que j'aurais dû la préciser aussi
au début c'est encore une autre forme de
continuité territoriale pour faire en
sorte que davantage de davantage de
membres de la famille puisse assister
assister malheureusement aux obsèques de
aux obsèques de leur famille en
métropole lorsque cela est nécessaire
donc sur sur
cette aide donc peut-être sur sur une
autre une autre réforme qui va bientôt
arriver et celle de la prise en charge
va de l'évaluation aussi du montant de
prise en charge de la continuité
territoriale à décret doit sortir
incessamment et qui permet de mettre en
oeuvre une de mettre en oeuvre une
mesure qui a été permises par un
amendement de la de la de la loi de
finance pour pour 2023 et qui permet de
réévaluer les montants de prise en
charge de décret doit sortir d'un moment
à l'autre il a été signé par par les
ministres et donc là il s'agit de
réévaluer le pourcentage de cette de
cette prise en charge par rapport au
coût du billet donc on va tangente on
peut cette prise en charge pour aller
jusque 50% de prix du billet comme cela
a été annoncé par le par le ministre
délégué aux outre-mer monsieur monsieur
karengo donc voilà pour deux de réformes
assez récentes pour pour le reste ce
sera effectivement le projet de le
projet la Dom 2024 qui permettra aussi
d'aller plus loin et de prendre en
compte aussi de nouveaux besoins de
de vos bullition de nouveaux publics
cette réforme
cette réforme que vous avez que vous
avez souligné qui vous a déjà été un
petit peu décrite je crois par le
président le directeur de la Dom
s'explique par un contexte très
particulier de cette année 2023 déjà
s'il s'agit de la fin de la
prescriptions de formation
professionnelle par l'adom dans une
logique de rationalisation puisque les
formations professionnelles et
prescriptions de formation
professionnelle sont maintenant prises
en charge par Pôle emploi et donc cette
cette réforme permet maintenant à la Dom
de se réinterroger sur ces missions et
sur le sur son adaptation aux besoins
des ultramarins il y a des pistes très
intéressantes qui ont été qui ont été
d'ores et déjà définis une autre raison
pardon je vais les aborder tout de suite
après une autre raison de cette de cette
réforme de ces réflexions cette année
tiennent aussi
à la fin de du contrat d'objectif et de
performance le COP le COP actuel prend
fin cette année en 2023
autre autre autre raison de ces
réflexions c'est le rapprochement avec
la Délégation interministérielle pour
l'égalité des chances des Français de
loutre des Français d'outre-mer et la
visibilité des Outre-mer la Diagon vie
et donc là aussi il s'agit de prendre en
compte se rapprochement pour ouvrir de
nouveaux champs d'action pour pour la
DOM et bien sûr de l'arrivée d'un
nouveau président d'un nouveau directeur
général à la Dom doivent permettre de
donner une nouvelle impulsion à
l'établissement en lien avec le
ministère délégué chargé des Outre-mer
donc les premières les premières
réflexions
apportent porte sur les l'ouverture de
la continuité territoriale faut-il
effectivement éventuellement revoir les
seuils les seuils d'accès faut-il
élargir à de nouveaux publics ça c'est
une réflexion très importante puisque on
voit qu'aujourd'hui certes effectivement
il faut aider les étudiants mais il y a
sans doute effectivement il faut sans
doute s'ouvrir au porteur de projet nous
avons un exemple très concret qui est
celui des startups d'outre-mer nous
avons la chance d'avoir une french tech
dynamique outre-mer et c'est il y a une
sorte de d'inégalité entre les startups
ultramarines et les startups de
métropole puisqu'elles peuvent pas se
rendre comme elles le souhaitent pour
participer à des salons en métropole ou
rencontrer des investisseurs donc ça
montre effectivement que les porteurs de
projets peuvent centres doivent sans
doute profiter davantage de la
continuité territoriale donc c'est le
chant de le chant des réflexions qui
sont qui sont en cours aujourd'hui il y
a également tout le champ de
l'accompagnement des étudiants puisque
c'était déjà un champ que nous avions
beaucoup poussé la Dom accompagne les
étudiants les personnes en formation en
métropole mais effectivement il faudra
qu'elle les accompagne davantage sur
l'ensemble de leurs projets c'est-à-dire
que le projet soit défini très en amont
avec ces jeunes pour que ils aient aussi
un projet de retour quand ils le
souhaitent des offres des offres
d'emploi qui puisse aussi profiter d'une
certaine réflexion de gestion
prévisionnelle des emplois et des
compétences en parallèle nous menons ces
réflexions pour se projeter dans les
emplois de demain et pas simplement
effectivement dans les emplois de
d'aujourd'hui donc cette réflexion a
débuté en Guadeloupe
un autre champ de réflexion porte sur le
dispositif cadre d'avenir qui existe
aujourd'hui pour Wallis-et-Futuna la
Nouvelle-Calédonie et Mayotte donc nous
ce dispositif a montré ses à montrer
tout son intérêt et lorsque nous avions
commencé à échangé avec des acteurs de
notamment des de Guadeloupe de la
Martinique et c'était montré
particulièrement intéressé par ce
dispositif qui en fait repose sur une
aide qui est versée à l'étudiant qui
vient faire ses études en métropole mais
effectivement à condition que ces études
correspondent à un besoin des
entreprises ultramarines encore une fois
on est sur de la partie GPEC gestion de
prévisionnelle des emplois et des
compétences et
cette aide permet de verser une aide à
l'étudiant une aide supplémentaire par
rapport à ce qui existe aujourd'hui avec
la prise en charge du billet du billet
pour les pour les étudiants par la DOM
et en échange de cette aide
supplémentaire l'étudiant s'engage à
revenir ensuite au terme de ses études
et sachant qu'il peut aussi avoir un
cours emploi aussi à la sortie de ces
études dans l'Hexagone donc le
l'étudiant s'engage à revenir dans son
territoire d'origine donc c'est un
processus qui que l'on qui a que le sol
pour lequel nous avons travaillé
beaucoup nous avons largement travaillé
avec les acteurs de Guadeloupe et il
sera mis en oeuvre et de Saint-Martin
également et donc il sera mis en oeuvre
à la rentrée 2023 pour les étudiants de
de Guadeloupe et de Martinique et
effectivement une l'expérimentation
aussi concerne cette dans un cadre d'une
expérimentation pardon et cette
expérimentation concernera aussi la
Martinique mais en décalé à partir de
2002-2024 puisque il y a tout un travail
préalable qui est nécessaire voici
quelques exemples de d'avancer
effectivement là pour les
expérimentation on sera on pourra très
bientôt effectivement vous pourrez très
bientôt
découvrir le texte qui permettra cette
expérience qui est en cours de
finalisation également et de signature
et également je vous ai évoqué les deux
les réformes récentes celles de 2021
celle qui doit intervenir par un décret
permettant de rehausser permettant de
rehausser les plafonds
et donc et j'ai effectivement voilà un
petit peu à grand près les travaux qui
sont menés dans le cadre du projet la
Dom la Dom 2024 donc on est vraiment
dans l'idée que les de plus en plus la
DOM et une action très complémentaire
par rapport au par rapport aux
formations dans les territoires je pense
que c'est très important d'assister sur
cette sur cette complémentarité les
formations de la Dom ne sont pas ne sont
pas concurrentes bien sûr d'une
formation dans les territoires et nous
nous félicitons aussi de divers indices
qui montrent que voilà les les de plus
en plus il y a une articulation entre
les formations de la Dom celle de la
formation si professionnelle qui existe
dans les territoires et aussi entre la
formation bien sûr des étudiants en dans
l'Hexagone par rapport à celle qui
existe dans dans les territoires et
certains chiffres semblent à tester que
voilà il y a de plus en il y a de plus
en plus effectivement cette
complémentarité qui montre encore une
fois qu'il y a pas du coup de
concurrence mais une complémentarité de
plus en plus recherché et un effort
aussi d'aide d'aide au retour également
des jeunes qui viennent se former grâce
à la Dom un petit indice sur ce cette
partie effectivement de d'augmentation
aussi des formations dans les
territoires quelques qui donnera
l'occasion de donner quelques chiffres
aussi sur les nombres de personnes
nombre de personnes accompagnées
s'agissant du passeport pour la mobilité
de la formation professionnelle
effectivement on a
on a des chiffres de bénéficiaires qui a
qui ont largement fluctué bien sûr dans
les années qui viennent de s'écouler et
ceci bien sûr en lien direct avec la
pacte de la crise sanitaire il y avait
5000 bénéficiaires
donc
il y avait 5000 bénéficiaires et donc
auparavant avant la crise 4000 ans 2019
1600 2020 et un léger redressement
2021-2022 à 2500 depuis 2700
bénéficiaires en 2022 donc
certes effectivement ce cette baisse est
un et tu as imputé en premier lieu au
rapprochement entre la DOM et Pôle
emploi qui effectivement fait que Pôle
Emploi prend en charge les prescriptions
mais cette baisse s'explique également
par le développement de l'offre de
formation locale et puis aussi de
développement des actions en distanciel
donc on les habitude en partie évolué
aussi les habitudes de formation en
partie évolué en lien avec en lien avec
la crise en crise sanitaire et voilà ça
montre bien effectivement aussi le
développement des ces chiffres montrent
aussi le développement des formations
dans les dans les territoires pour
continuer aussi sur quelques sur
quelques chiffres et l'impact de la
crise de l'impact de la crise sanitaire
s'agissant de la continuité territoriale
les bénéficiaires étaient s'élevés à
23000 23000 personnes jusqu'à la ce
nombre a chuté à 7000 en 2020 en 2022 on
compte 50000 bénéficiaires mais il faut
tenir compte je pense que vous l'avez du
service sans doute dû le noter pendant
votre travaux de du repas de l'aide de
la Région Réunion sur le dispositif
national et donc en de ce
nom le nombre de bénéficiaires pendant
de l'île de la Réunion et monter de 3000
en 2020 à 28000 en 2022 et représente
aujourd'hui 56% de de la continuité
territoriale de l'ensemble des
territoires d'ensemble des territoires
d'outre-mer il s'agissons des passeport
pour la mobilité des études on comptait
11000 bénéficiaires par an avant la
crise bien sûr il y a une dépression
pendant la crise et qui s'est mais plus
légère puisqu'en fait il y a le nombre
c'est réduits à 10 000 étudiants et se
redressent légèrement en 2012 à 10500
étudiants
voilà quelques quelques éléments
éclairants un petit peu les réformes et
la volonté encore une fois de bien
prendre en compte tous les enjeux qui
sont si ceux de ceux de vos travaux à
travers le projet le projet de service
la Dom 2024 pour faire en sorte que la
Dom soit de plus en plus au service de
nos concitoyens ultramarins et puis
s'adapter de manière très très fine aux
besoins qui sont au besoin qui sont aux
besoins qui sont identifiés et aux
différents aux différents enjeux
peut-être
pouvons-nous continuer si vous le si
vous le souhaitez sur la partie
budgétaire parce que j'ai terminé par
des des
quantifications du nombre de
bénéficiaires et le miroir de tout cela
est aussi
les dépenses sont aussi les dépenses
budgétaires et leurs évolutions au cours
de ces dernières récentes années
sous l'angle budgétaire je vais
peut-être commencer par par rappeler ce
que vous avez bien en tête c'est à dire
que la Dom est alimentée par deux
programmes par les deux programmes
budgétaires de du ministère des chargés
des autres mères donc programme 138
emplois qui supporte tous les
dispositifs
de formation professionnelle avec tout
ce que ma collègue vient de signaler
d'évolution en termes de prescription et
le programme 123 conditions de vie
outre-mer qui lui porte la continuité
territoriale proprement dite alors c'est
important parce que les chiffres que je
vais vous donner je vais essayer de pas
trop vous en donner mais vous en donner
quand même
ne porte que sur la dimension continuité
territoriale
il y a aussi bien entendu des crédits
d'intervention
sur la partie formation
donc je vais peut-être pas remonter en
tout cas dans les chiffres que je vous
donne jusqu'à 2013 parce que sinon ça
risque d'être un peu long ce que je peux
peut-être faire c'est faire un petit
focus sur 2022 2023
et puis
donner quelques indications sur la
trajectoire qu'on a retracé depuis 2013
alors
il y a dans ce qui est versé à la Dom
aussi une subvention pour charges de
service public subvention pour charge de
service public c'est ce qui donnait à
tout tout opérateur à partir du moment
où il a effectivement des décharges pour
répondre
interne pour répondre
aux obligations qui lui sont faites
alors cette subvention
[Musique]
n'évolue pas d'une façon majeure d'une
année à l'autre elle était en 2022 de 7
millions 3 et l'aide du même niveau
pardon en 2022 donc 7003 en 2023 elle
est du même ordre de grandeur
la Dom a eu certaines années vous
l'aurez dans les chiffres aussi des des
dotations spéciales pour investir en
interne ça a été le cas en 2017 et en
pour pouvoir travailler sur ces systèmes
numériques de les produits les
applications métiers les applications
budgétaires leur interface ça représente
sur la période
2013-2023 27 c'est pas dimensionnant
mais enfin il faut l'avoir en tête sur
la continuité territoriale proprement
dit donc là les chiffres agglomères la
continuité territoriale
j'allais dire de monsieur tout le monde
c'est les déplacements pour tout motif
qui sont comment dirais-je aider par la
Dom sous conditions de ressources mais
aussi
la partie continue du territoriale des
dispositifs de formation donc on a bien
les les deux dépenses en 2022 elle était
de 23 millions je parle des crédits
disponibles des crédit votés et en 2023
évidemment il est supérieur puisque
les amendements qui ont été adoptés en
projet de loi de finance sont venus
augmenter la dotation donc on est à 30
millions en 2023 en termes de de crédit
disponible
voilà alors ce qu'on constate dans dans
la trajectoire dont vous aurez encore
une fois les chiffres c'est
effectivement la le poids relatif de la
Réunion qui est évidemment considérable
et on l'envoie les effets à deux moments
on envoie les les effets entre 2014 et
les années qui suivent avec une
réduction
assez significative des crédits parce
que le dispositif mis en place par la
Région Réunion et à aspirer la demande
et on envoie en sens inverse en
2022 et en 2023 les effets puisque
là la dépense reprend les chiffres en
termes de volume de demande de vous ont
été donnés à l'instant par Isabelle
Richard donc c'est c'est effectivement
quelque chose qui est immédiatement des
slable dans les chiffres alors ça ça
c'est en termes de de
crédit disponible en termes de crédit
consommé
en 2022 tout de Rome confondus on était
à 16 millions cinq
voilà avec alors je le précise la
continuité funéraire qui est un
dispositif
important évidemment
de par sa portée sur le principe il
reste faible année après année en terme
de consommation
sur sur
2022 on était tout de Rome confondu à
130 000 euros donc c'est
c'est quelque chose qui alors pour pour
différentes raisons il existe des
régimes assurantiels
il existe peut-être aussi
une méconnaissance du dispositif enfin
tout ça est à analysé mais c'est quelque
chose qui ne consomme pas beaucoup donc
tout de Rome confondu 16 millions 5
disais en 2022 évidemment les chiffres
2023 nous ne
les a pas encore sur sur le Pacifique
on est sur 2022 à une dépense de 4
millions et demi voilà donc 3 millions 3
millions de 3800 sur la
Nouvelle-Calédonie à peu près 500 000
euros sur Wallis et Futuna et un million
100 sur la Polynésie française
voilà alors évidemment je vous donnera
tous les chiffres depuis 2013 mais je
vais pas vous infliger une longue
litanie de de chiffres qui perdrait tout
le monde
monsieur le Président j'ai oublié
d'indiquer dans les aspects aussi de
nouvelles mesures également deux mesures
à attendre pour 2023 j'ai évoqué la
revalorisation des montants maximum de
prise en charge effectivement je
oubliais d'indiquer également que ont
été votés en loi de finance une mesure
pour renforcer la continuité
territoriale pour les personnes
effectuant des VAE des validations
d'acquis de l'expérience avec un montant
de 1 million en dotation supplémentaires
et puis également une revalorisation de
un million d'euros pour le deuxième
accompagnant de de familial d'enfants
évacués sanitaires puisque aujourd'hui
la sécurité sociale prend en charge le
déplacement à 100% du premier parent pas
du deuxième parent donc effectivement
nous travaillons aussi sur une
disposition complémentaire qui a été
demandée par plusieurs parlementaires
merci je propose maintenant de laisser
la parole à Monsieur vivait de la DGAC
monsieur le Président bonjour Emmanuel
Vivet donc la direction du transport
aérien quelques observations donc sur le
transport aérien avec les outre-mer
les départements d'outre-mer sont des
territoires européens et à ce titre ils
sont inclus dans le régime européen de
du marché intérieur qui est un marché
libéralisé
toute compagnie européenne peut à tout
moment commencer un service entre
notamment la métropole et n'importe
quelle des dômes et entre les deux
hommes entre eux sans avoir besoin
d'autorisation de la Direction générale
de l'aviation civile dure simple
notification qui nous parvient de nos
systèmes informatiques ce qui permet
donc aujourd'hui d'avoir trois
compagnies aériennes qui desservent les
Antilles quatre compagnies qui
desservent la Réunion 2 sur Cayenne
pratiquement 5 sur Tahiti si on compte
les compagnies américaines qui se
précipitent à Papeete actuellement
la Nouvelle-Calédonie est un cas
particulier particulièrement loin avec
RK et puis deux transporteurs sur
Mayotte aujourd'hui
donc c'est un niveau de concurrence qui
est élevé pour des lignes long-courrier
que nous connaissons sur très peu de
liaisons de de cette longueur
le régime économique est tel que
finalement les transporteurs cherchent
comme toujours à gagner de l'argent
Air Caraïbes est une entreprise privée
French be également du même groupe
familial Corsair est une entreprise
détenue par des intérêts privés Air
France est détenu effectivement à 28%
par l'État mais un comportement
d'acteurs privés dans la mesure où il
est coté en bourse donc ces entreprises
cherchent à gagner de l'argent les
marges d'après nous sont assez faibles
voire négatives
pour s'en convaincre il suffit de se
souvenir de la faillite Dawei Air
Liberté de celle de XL Airways en 2019
d'Open Sky level qui attaque à arrêter
ses services en 2020 et a fermé sa mise
en liquidation judiciaire
Corsair qui a eu besoin d'un plan d'aide
en 2020 et Air Austral tout à fait
récemment comme nous le savons tous donc
ce sont des lignes qui sont
concurrentielles
et la concurrence fait son œuvre
on peut regarder le sujet d'un autre
point de vue qui suit des tarifs
nous n'avons pas l'obligation de suivre
les tarifs sur toute les liaisons du
monde il y en a environ 1500 qui
touchent la France mais on le fait sur
un certain nombre de liaison on le fait
sur les DOM-TOM depuis une certain temps
donc la l'administration a monté un
robot tarifaire qui interroge les sites
Internet qui remontent de l'information
pas sur toutes les classes de
réservation parce qu'il y en a 16 mais
sur un certain nombre de liaisons et
certains de classe et donc on a un bon
suivi sur les DOM
et nous arrivons en conclusion suivante
qui est que
certes les tarifs font augmenter en 2022
ils avaient diminué en 2021 en sortie de
crise
ils ont augmenté parce que le prix du
kérosène principalement à monter de 94%
d'après nos observations entre septembre
2021 et septembre 2022 je parle du prix
du kérosène en euros car le dollar a
monté donc comme kérosène se paye en
dollars est indexé sur le dollar on a un
double hausse à prendre en compte dans
le cas particulier des Antilles il y a
une petite os qui a été rajoutée à
travers la Sarah de 15% au total cette
hausse est nécessairement répercutée en
toute ou partie sur les transporteurs
sur les passagers pardon
et
ça c'est pour l'évolution pour ceux qui
concerne le niveau des tarifs
risque de vous surprendre
nous pouvons affirmer qu'avant en crise
en 2019 le tarif
au kilomètre et au passager
était sur les liaisons vers les dômes
33% plus bas que la moyenne mondiale de
distance comparable
et au risque de vous surprendre à
nouveau à l'arrivée enfin je me place à
l'automne 2022 fin de notre étude
analytique à ce moment là mais on doit
pas être très loin
dans un contexte inflationniste général
de toutes les liaisons dans le monde le
tarif au kilomètre passager transporté
était à ce moment-là 41% plus bas que la
moyenne mondiale mondiale je dirais
toutes les compagnies sur toute les
liaisons que ça soit Tokyo Tokyo
Brisbane voilà on mélange tout on prend
les Indiens les Chinois toute l'Afrique
toute la toute la concurrence
internationale au départ des États-Unis
on arrive à 41% plus bas que la moyenne
mondiale cependant il est certain que la
saisonnalité des tarifs est plus grande
sur les dômes qu'elle ne l'est sur des
lignes
long-courrier elle était avant la crise
et elle l'est toujours cette
saisonnalité et même elle s'est un peu
accentuée et donc le ressenti des
passagers qui achètent un billet
peut être assez fort si évidemment on
achète un billet une semaine avant
et si en plus c'est la mauvaise période
on tombe sur des plantes tomber sur des
prix élevés dont on se souviendra
longtemps
d'un point de vue réglementaire nous ne
disposons pas d'outils d'encadrement des
tarifs qui sont libres comme je
l'expliquais précédemment c'est un
régime libéralisé article 22 du
règlement européen pertinent
il y a une petite exception sur depuis
1997 et je remarque que cette exception
est antérieure au règlement européen sur
les jeunes dont les DOM donc pour les
moins de 2 ans les moins de 12 ans et
les moins de 18 ans il y a des
réductions obligatoires ces réductions
sont
prises en compte par les transporteurs
qui nécessairement les répercutent sur
les autres voyageurs puisque comme il y
a pas de compensation il agisse de cette
manière c'est normal
et puis je crois que vous aviez des
questions sur la Guyane qui est un
régime particulier puisque en Guyane le
territoire est très dense très très
grand très très particulier
et donc il y a des liaisons absolument
indispensables à la continuité pour pour
territorial pour l'activité économique
la population les études entre un
certain nombre de villes Cayenne Paris
parceoula Saül etc donc il y a 5 lignes
d'aménagement du territoire qui sont
installés dans le territoire guyanais
ce sont des lignes qui sont intérieures
à la région guyanaise et par conséquent
elle dépendent de la région guyanaise la
région lyonnaise prend elle-même les
obligations de service public qu'elle
estime nécessaire nous sommes à sa
disposition pour l'aider nous le faisons
bien sûr elle elle a on peut constater
une donc une amélioration du dispositif
nous pensons que le système amélioré en
2021 lorsqu'il est passé d'une aide à la
personne
à un système de délégation de service
public où on demande aux concurrents aux
transporteur de proposer la compensation
la plus basse possible afin qu'ils
soient retenue c'est ce que nous
pratiquons en métropole et nous pensons
que c'est la meilleure manière en tout
cas les moins inflationniste que la
méthode consistant à aider chaque
voyageur à voyager
j'en ai fini monsieur le Président et je
me tiens disponible sur des questions
merci en mettant passé au ministère de
la santé et de la prévention
pour les propos introductifs
quand à tous donc il Mouillard pour la
Direction de la Sécurité sociale
je crois une des premières de première
interrogation portait sur
le niveau de prise en charge des
patients au sein des territoires
eux-mêmes avant même de parler des
espaces peut-être en propose l'action du
ministère du ministère de la santé des
comptes publics
consiste avant tout à accompagner voire
développer l'offre de soins dans les
territoires pour limiter tant que faire
ce peu le besoin recours des évasables
mais que ceci reste néanmoins parfois
nécessaire sur le territoire je crois
qu'une de vos questions étaient de
savoir en cas d'éloignement du domicile
du patient par rapport au prise en
charge sur le territoire lui-même
qualité des conditions de prise en
charge donc sur les sur les charges de
soins les la prise en charge est celle
du droit commun sur le les transports
sanitaires peut-être rappelé que le code
de la sécurité sociale prévoit ce motif
de prise en charge l'assurance maladie
des transports sanitaires
dont les transports liés à une
spécialisation par exemple les
transports en ambulance quand l'état des
malades justifie ou les transports a un
lieu distant de plus de 150 km
un dispositif qui peut aussi être mis en
avant et qui trouve à prospérer dans les
territoires d'outre-mer c'est celui dit
des hôtels hospitaliers
qu'on appelle l'hébergement temporaire
non médicalisé
qui a été expérimenté à partir de 2015
généralisé en 2021
et qui sur prescription médicale permet
qu'impatient puisse être hébergé
quand les conditions notamment
d'éloignement le nécessitent sur le site
hospitalier ou dans un hôtel qui est un
partenariat avec avec l'établissement
dans ce cadre là
le dispositif est aussi ouvert aux
patients et vassané en métropole et les
plafonds qui existent nuités à savoir 3
unités consécutives sans actes ou 21ités
rattachés à un séjour hospitalier sont
levés pour les patients d'outre-mer qui
sont dévastés
et donc qui permettent du coup un
hébergement de ses patients en métropole
sur un site non médicalisé donc proche
de l'établissement qui lui dispense les
soins
donc je disais les évaçades malgré tout
on en compte environ 700 700 par an qui
répondent aux crises air strict des
élastiques dans une instruction récente
de décembre 2022 donc vous avez
probablement connaissance
qui définit ce que sont les évasanes à
quel critères cumulatif
à répondre ses évasses et quelles sont
les modalités de prise en charge
qu'est-ce qui est pris en charge et par
qui il y a deux vecteurs de financement
pour les abassades directement par la
caisse d'assurance maladie
ou par l'établissement qui organise
l'évacuation selon que les vaccins
s'organisaient par un avion de ligne
régulière ou par un avion sanitaire
l'assurance maladie prenant en charge
directement les dépenses
dans le cadre d'évacuation par un avion
de ligne régulière et l'établissement
prenant en charge les les frais liés à
une évacuation par avion sanitaire dans
ce cadre là son prix en charge
évidemment le transport du patient
lui-même de l'équipe soignante mais
également d'un accompagnement d'un
accompagnement d'un accompagnant
pour un assurer ou un ayant droit soit
parce que son état le justifie soit
parce que le patient est façonné à moins
de 16 ans
en complément de ce dispositif le fond
d'action sanitaires et sociale des
caisses peut prendre le relais prend le
relais même régulièrement et comme je
crois c'est souligné dans votre
questionnaire pour les CGSS
ces actions en faveur en complément des
prises en charge des vacanes et
particulièrement prénom dans les
territoires
d'outre-mer en dernier recensement en
2019 on comptait 2,7 millions d'euros
engagés au titre de ce fond d'action
sociale et sanitaire
enfin profit en accompagnement de
dispositifs des façades soit un peu plus
de 50% en moyenne de la dotation dit
paramétrique de ces caisses
il ne reste pas moins que ce fond
d'action sociale évidemment intervient
en fonction de la situation sociale est
souvent sous conditions de revenus des
patients donc du coup ce n'est pas ce ne
sont pas des positifs un accompagnement
qui est ouvert à l'ensemble
à l'ensemble de la population mais bien
sûr sous condition
vous aviez également des interrogations
sur le fait que les vacanes prennent en
charge depuis le domicile du patient ou
entre établissement alors le principe de
la bassin c'est que c'est pris en charge
etc transfert d'établissement
établissement parce qu'une des
conditions c'est que le patient soit
hospitalisée pour autant des relais sont
prévus par les transporteurs
c'est-à-dire par le transport sanitaire
tel qu'il est prévu qu'il soit pris en
charge par le code de la sécurité
sociale
sur le nombre d'accompagnants donc un
accompagnant est prévu donc je disais
pour les enfants de moins de 16 ans
notamment ou quand l'état de du tir ou
de l'ayant droit le justifie
sur les modalités de prise en charge la
règle générale et que c'est plutôt alors
où la caisse d'assurance maladie ou
l'établissement qui fait l'avance de
frais mais en vie réelle on observe un
peu tous les cas de figure il est pas
rare que une famille fallait même
l'avance ça se rembourser ensuite mais
la règle générale le principe de base
est celui-ci c'est la caisse ou
l'établissement qui prend en charge en
première intention les frais les frais
associés
vous nous interrogiez également sur le
cas des rapatriements de corps en cas de
décès
pour vous confirmer que l'assurance
maladie n'intervient pas
en principe sur le la prise en charge du
rap patrimoine des corps cependant là
aussi le fond d'action sociale et
sanitaire
peut prendre en charge en général
hauteur de 1000 euros et sous conditions
de ressources là encore
les frais liés assez rapatriement de
corps a peut-être une exception à noter
les cas de décès à la suite un accident
du travail qui font l'objet d'une prise
d'une prise en charge
s'agissant du coût global de la
continuité des soins la question elle
aura été posée à l'assurance maladie et
aux équipes en charge de des analyses
médicaux économiques communister on ne
sait pas le chiffre aisément on ne sait
pas identifier le coût de prise en
charge des soins des passions
d'outre-mer qui ont été évacées c'est
pas quelque chose dont je dispose
facilement ça pourrait probablement
travailler mais c'est pas quelque chose
qui a été étudié qui a été étudié à ce
stade
et que on est en capacité de vous
restituer ici
monsieur le Président bonjour Pierre
Savary pour la DGOS peut-être un
complément parce que vous aviez une
question sur les Evasan pardon urgentes
et vous demandiez si elle se faisait
dans des conditions satisfaisantes je
crois que oui donc pour ces évacés
encore coordonnées par les Samus il y a
eu deux chantiers notables qui ont été
qui ont été évoqués en partie par
Guillaume billard d'abord un chantier
financier avec la création d'une mission
intérêt général dédiée dans le cadre de
la réforme de financement des urgences
qui a permis de clarifier ce financement
mais s'en est suivi une augmentation des
moyens avec des revalorisations assez
conséquentes en 2021 puis en 2022
puisque cette ce vecteur de financement
est passé de 5,8 millions à 17 millions
en 2022 voilà et puis donc à côté de ce
chantier financier un chantier de de
définition de redéfinition des évasales
c'est l'instruction du 5 décembre 2022
qui a déjà été évoqué et qui a permis
voilà de clarifier le périmètre
ainsi que le financement dans la
continuité du chantier du chantier
financier il y a
c'est vraiment chantier organisationnel
devant nous avec des défis clairement
identifiés que nous remontent les ARS et
les acteurs c'est d'abord tirer les
leçons de la crise sanitaire puisqu'en
fait les organisations en place ont
évolué on l'a vu par exemple à Mayotte
ou un avion sanitaire dédié cet avéré
nécessaire il a été maintenu c'est aussi
pour ça que le financement était
augmenté en 2021 en 2022 des difficultés
particulières donc à Mayotte qui sont
liés aussi à au contexte d'immigration
comorienne à une augmentation une
augmentation des voilà des besoins
dépassés
urgents mais une diminution notable des
délais grâce à cet avion dédié contexte
particulier aussi en Guyane avec la
question des transports intérieurs qui
bien connaît pas des évasales sont en
général le préalable à une évacuation
vers la métropole pardon avec donc des
transports multifectoriels qui qui
suppose toute une logistique et là aussi
il y a des bonnes pratiques sans doute à
échanger à consolider dans le cadre de
ce chantier organisationnel qui est
encore en partie en partie devant nous
voilà c'est la question du lien avec les
communes intérieures les CDPS mais on
aura peut-être l'occasion d'y revenir il
y a des d'autres chantiers qui sont qui
sont devant nous qui concerne tous les
outre-mer c'est la question de minimiser
le temps d'indisponibilité de des
équipes médicaux-soignantes puisque on
parle ici de transport qui sont
médicalisés il faut prévoir donc l'aller
et le retour pour ces équipes le retour
des matériels également mais globalement
voilà grâce aux deux chantiers que
j'évoquais en premier lieu financier et
de redéfinition je crois qu'il y a une
amélioration dans la plupart des
territoires qui nous ont fait ces
remonter récemment
bien écoutez je vous remercie je mettais
en laisser la parole à nos rapporteur
j'ai pas qui de Guillaume Chevrollier ou
Catherine Catherine si tu veux commencer
oui
pardon oui président oui j'ai quelques
questions merci beaucoup je salue toutes
les déguisations présentes et on
remercie pour te les prévisions qui nous
ont été apportés donc pour votre
information et vous dit que je suppose
que Guillaume le sera aussi et moi-même
on sera assez précisions un certain
nombre de questions parce que nous nous
sommes déplacés en Guyane et en
Guadeloupe où il y a de vrais
problématiques de continuité plus plus
et nous avons pu sur le tirer évaluer la
mise en oeuvre de certains nombre de
mesures qui relèvent de la continuité
territoriale
excusez-moi
j'ai quelques questions mais qui sont
très courtes donc je vais vous les poser
tout de suite et ensemble qu'est-ce que
la Dom appelle un public modeste
deuxième question
est-ce que la dernière réforme de 2021 a
fait l'objet d'une évaluation
quand on dit troisième question quand on
dit 50% du prix du billet est-ce que
vous pouvez préciser le plafond
50 % de 1500 euros
c'est souvent le cas classique ou ça a
été souvent le cas en classico et ça
laissait certainement sur des périodes
dites deux pointes
je suis quasiment sûr que la Dom ne
donne pas 750 euros autrement dit la
moitié
toujours concernant la Dom pourquoi ce
besoin de temps dentaire et parpillé
dans tout l'hexagone avec bien sûr les
frais de fonctionnement qui vont avec
vous savez parler pour la partie
sécurité sociale
d'hébergement
non médicalisée
j'aimerais attirer votre attention sur
la situation de la Guyane et de la
Guadeloupe que nous avons pu voir de
près avec vraiment une situation que je
trouve déplorable
ce qui vient de l'intérieur du pays par
exemple de mal basula et qui parle sur
Cayenne pour être pour être soigné ou
pour accoucher c'est-à-dire des semaines
avant et le terme non nulle part ou
échoué nulle part et on est quand même
dans une continuité de santé
pareil pour ceux de l'archipel de
Guadeloupe qui se déplaît par exemple
comme nous l'avons comme ils nous a été
exposé de Marie-Galante à Guadeloupe
parfois tous les jours pour aller subir
des séances de chimiothérapie vont à
l'hôpital et se retrouve dans le hangar
la température du passé 40 degrés sous
tôle sans aucune installation pour
attendre le prochain bateau qui est
fondant dans l'après-midi
avec parfois 5 ou 6 heures d'attente
dans une gare pas très hospitalière il
faut le dire aucun dispositif sur place
d'accueil de ces personnes pour attendre
je vous laisse imaginer quelques cafés
une demi-heure 45 minutes de chimio et
qui retourne sur la gare parce qu'elle
n'a aucun point de chute nulle part où
aller c'est pas prévu et qui attend dans
ces conditions là j'ai interpellé
d'ailleurs le directeur du port dessus
et j'attends ses propositions
je suis aussi interpellée ça c'est la ma
dernière question de la première salle
sur la transparence et la communication
des mesures
les mesures ne sont pas connues du grand
public ou très peu vraiment très peu
alors les différentes personnes que nous
avons rencontrés nous disent on est en
train de progresser on participe à un
certain nombre de réunions etc mais
c'est pas connu et je suppose que c'est
un impact non équitable consommation que
l'on voit qui sont
obtenus des enjeux relativement faibles
voilà je vous ai posé des questions et
en premier bien sûr
celle de la définition de public modeste
dans les outre-mer quand on connaît les
niveaux de vie les niveaux de pauvreté
le coût de la vie et lorsque par exemple
pour avoir une acété le niveau de de
ressources de exiger ne dépasse pas les
12000 euros ça je vous avoue que ça m'a
fait beaucoup sourire mes sourires
d'amertume voilà j'en ai terminé
oui merci madame messieurs pour pour vos
interventions en complément de ma
collègue effectivement de retour d'un
déplacement on a pu mesurer à quel point
il y avait de fortes attentes en matière
de continuité territoriale et comme vous
l'avez dit Madame il y a pas une
continuité mais dès continuités
continuité des territoires ultramarins
vers l'Hexagone mais la continuité
intérieure et aussi la forte demande
d'une continuité vers les autres
territoires
ultramarins et également les territoires
enfin quand par rapport à la Guyane les
pays voisins la mobilité est compliquée
donc en complément sur cette première
série de questions par rapport à ce que
ce qui évoquait ma collègue qu'on
rapporteur
l'accès à l'information sur les
dispositifs les niveaux de ressources
pour accéder aux dispositif la Dom sont
particulièrement faibles donc ça limite
quand même les possibilités pour un
certain nombre de public
donc ça c'est vraiment les les retours
terrains très très fréquents que l'on a
eu au travers d'une diversité de
rencontres donc ça c'est des points dans
la réforme la DOM ou dans les réflexions
vous pouvez avoir qui sont qui sont à
mon sens à
intégrer
et de développer une offre alors si vous
avez indiqué que les prix étaient dans
la moyenne alors avec sur nos
territoires ultramarins le point de la
saisonnalité qui est vraiment
problématique pour ceux qui qui ont
besoin de d'aller en métropole pour pour
se former il y a quand même des des
périodes avec des dates impératives donc
là il y a un vrai sujet
à traiter
et donc c'est les points les premiers
points que je voulais aborder et puis
vous avez
pas répondu à la une des questions du
questionnaire là sur la raie de la Cour
administrative d'appel de Bordeaux
commence à ça vous fait réagir et sur la
puisqu'on voit que les collectivités
locales
[Musique]
mesurant les attentes de leur population
par rapport aux besoins de continuité
encore une fois intérieure extérieurs
ont envie d'accompagner donc il faut
pouvoir
sécuriser juridiquement cette
possibilité à défaut que l'État
abondent davantage sur sur les moyens
pour pour permettre une continuité
effective
et vous avez indiqué la question qui
serait plus sur la dgsc
la réglementation européenne qui
s'impose effectivement
mais ça s'est subi aussi comme étant une
forme de contrainte est-ce que
vous pouvez est-ce qu'on peut réduire
ces contraintes ou qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce qui pourrait
lever un certain nombre d'obstacles pour
permettre et accroître les possibilités
de mobilité et d'offres merci
bien sûr à plusieurs voix
et voilà je passerai éventuellement la
parole à mes collègues pour quelques
compléments donc effectivement sur le
public modeste alors c'est vrai que
voilà ce terme modeste
et
reflète en fait le la notification qui
était faite à la Commission européenne
du dispositif dans son renouvellement à
la Commission européenne a beaucoup
insisté sur le fait pas la que ce
qu'elle a prouvé ce dispositif parce
qu'il était orienté vers des publics
modestes bien évidemment donc dans qu'on
prend la philosophie et on comprend
aussi que cette philosophie ne va pas
bien sûr à l'encontre des intérêts des
Outre-mer puisque dans d'autres champs
on sait que notamment pour le chant du
logement social 80 ou 90% des de nos
concitoyens ultramarins même si
effectivement on peut le regretter bien
sûr sont éligibles au logement au
sociaux donc ça veut bien dire que voilà
non nous avons aujourd'hui un public qui
est majoritairement effectivement
modeste outre-mer alors en réalité
qu'est-ce que cela recouvre donc ça
recouvre aujourd'hui un quotient
familial annuel je parle sous le
contrôle de mes collègues précisément le
montant que j'ai et
11991 euros pour la continuité
territoriale et pour le passeport
mobilité étude et la formation
professionnelle de 26631 euros c'est
bien cela donc effectivement nous avons
conscience que ces montants ont été
fixés il y a plusieurs années bien
évidemment les revenus ont pu progresser
donc c'est un sujet qui qui regardait
aussi dans le cadre de la réforme de la
réforme de la Dom mais pour autant pour
autant il faut il faudra regarder si on
est éloigné ou pas de des revenus médian
médian outre-mer qui sont qui sont ces
revenus médias encore une fois outre-mer
sont plus sont plus faibles
bien sûr que dans d'autres que dans
d'autres territoires de de l'Hexagone
donc il faut regarder aussi par rapport
aux revenus aux revenus médian bien sûr
des des populations ultramarines donc et
il faut garder à l'esprit encore une
fois la notification de la Commission
européenne sur la base de ressources
effectivement de la publicité d'un
public dit modeste donc voilà pour le la
partie caution familial si il faudrait
ajouter encore une fois avec mes
collègues pourront me pourront me
compléter alors la dernière réforme de
2021 il est encore trop tôt d'après nous
pour pour vraiment effectivement tirer
les enseignements déjà effectivement les
textes les textes sortis en cours
d'année 2021 aussi en lien avec la
période de confinement donc on a les
premiers mois 2021 étaient des mois de
confinement et donc le le texte sont
sortis il n'y avait aucune utilité de
sortir ces textes en début 2021 donc ils
sortie au printemps au printemps 2021 il
y a eu ensuite encore d'autres périodes
de confinement bien sûr outremer avec
une pandémie qui a été ce qui a été
sévère par contre effectivement on voit
que sur la réévaluation des montants on
peut simplement poser des hypothèses et
la réévaluation notamment des montants
de prise en charge pour la Polynésie
avec une hausse du prix des tarifs
aériens en 2022 notamment par rapport à
2021 effectivement a joué en plein en
faveur bien sûr de ces de ces publics de
même que le passage d'un tarif unique de
pour les dromes un tarif majoré donc
bien entendu comme comme d'habitude je
sais pas si mon collègue souhaite le
préciser mais nous menons régulièrement
des évaluations
et au sein au sein de la dgom de des
différents dispositifs et effectivement
on aura à coeur d'évaluer bien sûr ce
cette réforme sur le montant de de
tangente qui Tang à 50% pour la prise en
charge de prix du billet on a
aujourd'hui aussi un dispositif assez
vertueux parce qu'en fait
on a il est assez incitatif pour les
particuliers comme pour les agences de
voyages pour anticiper le plus possible
les déplacements essayer d'avoir des et
aussi avoir des déplacements de ce fait
le la montant le plus intéressant
possible pour les pour les pour les
particuliers ce montant de 50% je base
aussi sur ce que sur le savoir de mes
collègues se base sur les montants
constatés de 2022 en matière de
continuité territoriale mais je vais
passer quand même la parole à mon
collègue pour quelques précisions parce
que c'était on s'est basé sur les
montants constatés de 2022 qui
effectivement montre une hausse une
hausse des prix et donc les prix ont été
réévalués pour tenir convalement le
montant plafond a été évalué pour en
tenir compte peut-être un petit mot un
petit mot sur ce point avec quelques
précisions donc
c'est vrai il est vrai que les les prix
ont augmenté en 2022 mais malgré tout
nous nous basons sur le la moyenne du
prix d'achat
du billet d'avion par les bénéficiaires
de l'aide à la continuité territoriale
nous ne nous basons pas sur le prix
d'achat tout public le prix d'achat
haute saison parmi les voilà et puisque
cette population
est des faits très attention à prendre
les billets les moins chers et aussi
parmi cette population qui a qui
bénéficie des aides à la continuité
territoriale il y a aussi des enfants
qui bénéficient de tarifs réduits la
moyenne est relativement basse par
exemple pour la Guadeloupe nous avons ce
sont les chiffres de la dame qui a fait
la moyenne des billets que la dôme
aidé
sur la Guadeloupe c'est 688 euros sur la
Martinique c'est 728 euros
donc nous avons sur la Réunion c'est 970
euros
dans le Pacifique bon en effet on est
dans le Pacifique il y a des des
chiffres beaucoup plus élevés Nouvelle
Calédonie 2061 euros
et voilà donc ce qui nous donne
aujourd'hui
quand on calcule combien font c'est 50 %
et bien ça donne les montants qui sont
inscrits dans le projet d'arrêté qui
doit sortir davantage au Journal
officiel donc ce sont on se base sur du
réaliser mais de l'ensemble de l'année
en fait même si on se focalise pas
encore une fois sur les saisons hautes
malgré tout les chiffres de l'année
englobe ces tarifs qui augmentent qui
augmentent plus particulièrement
notamment à l'été ou en fin d'année donc
c'est ces tarifs englobe englobe c'est
effectivement toute l'année donc y
compris les parties les billets plus
fort effectivement qui sont plus forts
dans de ces plus importants lors de ces
périodes donc c'est vraiment sur la base
du réaliser
et encore une fois qu'avec un dispositif
qui est assez incitatif et qui favorise
aussi indirectement la concurrence
puisque ça force aussi les compagnies à
offrir le meilleur tarif et aussi il y a
vertueux aussi pour les les finances
publiques mais dans ce cadre-là nous
avons bien effectivement souhaité faire
en sorte que les plafonds permettent une
prise en charge voilà jusqu'à 50% du
prix du billet par rapport à ce qui
était constaté donc ensuite sur les
antennes dans dans l'Hexagone
effectivement
monsieur rapporteur j'avais pas précisé
ce point mais c'est bien dans dans les
documents qui est tous les documents qui
vont vous être fournis au sérieusement à
cette à cette audition avec de nombreux
de nombreux éléments chiffrés également
apporté par par mon collègue en matière
budgétaire donc les éléments
effectivement complémentaires par
rapport à ce que nous avons pu indiquer
donc sur les sur les dispositifs
effectivement enfin sur les
implantations de la Dom effectivement il
y a
d'hommes mais aussi à la lumière de des
actions futures donc cela devrait être
pris en compte bien sûr dans le projet
dans le projet stratégique de la Dom la
Dom 2024 donc plus précisément la vous
trouverez dans des éléments de réponse
le fait que la répartition des TP ce qui
ce qui fait que en fait
33 c'est vrai qu'au 33% des agents de la
Dom de ce fait exerce dans les unités
territoriales de l'Hexagone mais il y a
effectivement une partie significative
qui dans effectivement avec 48 TP c'est
là où il y a le plus de TP 48 TP qui qui
exercent sur les unités territoriales
ultramarines
donc voilà pour la partie la partie
implantation je passerai bien sûr après
la parole à mes collègues des autres
ministères sur les questions qui
relèvent de leurs compétences sur les
demandes entre territoires effectivement
il y a des demandes de continuité la
première demande aussi qui avait été
formulée c'était aussi au titre de la
continuité funéraire puisque là il y a
le
dispositif de 2021 permet aussi la
continuité fine funéraire entre
territoires ultramarins et effectivement
il y a aussi des demandes nous savons de
notamment de Wallis et Futuna pour une
continuité territoriale avec avec la
Nouvelle-Calédonie donc là on serait par
définition hors du champ qui relève de
la compétence des territoires puisque là
les compétences étaient des territoires
valent comme ça a été comme ça a été
rappelé sur le propre leur propre
territoire c'est une compétence des
collectivités des collectivités locales
donc effectivement les demandes entre
peuvent être examinés au fur et à mesure
s'agissant de l'arrêt de la Cour
administrative d'appel de Bordeaux donc
cette
effectivement là aussi je n'avais pas
détaillé ce point dans ce point dans ma
réponse
excusez-moi pour plus de précisions je
vais me reporter aux éléments aux
éléments voilà de qui ont été indiqués
qui ont été indiqués nous sommes
effectivement nous avons nous avons
analysé cette arrêt donc effectivement
ce que ce qui est pointé par la Cour
administrative c'est effectivement
l'inégalité de de des financements de
des financements de la Réunion pour
pour l'aide à la continuité territoriale
mais rien n'est dit dans ce dans ce
jugement sur la délibération du conseil
régional qui attribue une dotation à la
Dom pour financer son dispositif à CT
autrement dit la cour appelle
administrative d'appel de Bordeaux ne se
prononce pas sur la question de la
participation de la collectivité ou
financement de la politique de la
continuité territoriale mais remet en
cause le fait que pour la région d'avoir
développé son propre dispositif de
continuité territoriale donc
effectivement
rien d'interdit aux collectivités de
participer financièrement via une
convention par exemple à la mise en
oeuvre des actions relatives à la
mobilité à la continuité territoriale
voilà ce qui ce qui semble assez logique
puisque voilà de le conventionnement
entre entre région et organisme
organisme public sont sont fréquents et
donc ça pourrait être tout à fait
possible pour pour la continuité pour la
continuité territoriale voilà peut-être
si je sais pas si
vous souhaitez
peut-être de ce fait je vais passer la
parole à mes collègues de la DGAC pour
de la DSS pour les questions qui
relèvent de leurs compétences
si vous êtes d'accord
je continue sur les assaisonnalité des
tarifs
vous m'avez interrogé sur cette
saisonnalité que on appelle dans le
langage technique le yil de management
c'est-à-dire que les entreprises tarifs
au coût marginal le dernier passager sur
carrivant sur un avion complètement
rempli va payer plus cher que le premier
arrivant sur un avion vide
c'est un système qui a été inventé aux
États-Unis dans les années 80 qui a été
développé avec pas mal d'énergie par Air
France dans les années 90 et qui
maintenant est enfin Air France et
d'autres toutes les entreprises bien
gérées aujourd'hui fonctionnent de cette
manière
et donc ça explique qu'effectivement les
tarifs sont plus élevés lorsqu'il y a
beaucoup de demandes et plus bas quand
il y en a moins
ça fait partie de la liberté tarifaire
c'est à dire que on ne on ne compte pas
le tarif comme étant enfin les
entreprises ont la liberté de manœuvrer
de sorte à pouvoir rentabiliser leurs
opérations donc
cette
conséquence de la libéralisation fait
partie donc d'un ensemble et
notre analyse c'est que la
libéralisation pour les dômes et bon
traiter la Nouvelle-Calédonie à part
mais est un bienfait elle l'a fait
baisser les prix elle a fait baisser les
prix et c'est pas moi qui le dit ce sont
les passagers on a toujours plus de
passagers on a ce sont le seul faisceau
au départ de la métropole qui dépasse de
loin les seuils de 2019 aujourd'hui
beaucoup plus que le l'Asie bien entendu
mais plus que l'Afrique plus que le
Maghreb plus que la métropole française
qui est à en chute de -30 20 30% de
sur certaines certains axes
l'Europe est un petit peu au-dessus si
vous voulez de son niveau 2019 les DOM
sont largement dessus
donc on a le passager nous dit que c'est
un
service qui lui est rendu et tout ceci
pour un coup de pour les finances
publiques et égal à zéro
donc les citoyens européens qu'ils
habitent en Martinique à la Réunion ou
à Brest en profite tous les jours
et vous me demandez comment peut-on
améliorer les choses
je il faudrait idéalement dans un monde
parfait trouver des compagnies qui
fassent des vols supplémentaires pendant
la haute saison
c'est ça qu'il faudrait qu'on ait c'est
qu'on est des avions en plus dans la
semaine de Noël si vous voulez donc
trouver quelqu'un qui soit disponible à
attendre la haute saison pour faire des
vols ou attendre le 1er juillet
par ailleurs ce que nous faisons déjà ce
que l'État fait déjà ce que le
contribuable fait finalement c'est de
maintenir les compagnies qui ont besoin
d'être maintenu en vie en vie des
centaines de millions d'euros ont été
dépensés pour pour sauver Air France
pour sauver corsaire pour sauver austral
et ça c'est énormément d'argent pour
transporter les gens il faut des
compagnies et si le marché était
rentable très rentable sur les doms on
aurait déjà Lufthansa ou Vueling ou
d'autres entreprises européennes qui
seraient sur ce marché puisqu'elles
n'ont pas besoin de notre autorisation
pour l'exploiter ses vols donc si elles
ne viennent pas c'est que ce n'est pas
si rentable que ça c'est plus rentable
pour elle d'aller exploiter du New York
ou du ou du Miami
qu'est-ce que peut faire le passager
c'est alors que
trouver des nouvelles compagnies ça je
ne sais pas comment on fait pour trouver
une compagnie qui attend de Noël et qui
attend le premier juillet pour venir
voler l'état des pensées beaucoup
d'argent pour pour sauver les
entreprises qui en avaient besoin le
passager lui de son côté évidemment doit
réserver son billet à l'avance car il
bénéficiera non seulement du bas du
cycle enfin de la partie basse de la
montée du cycle avant avant la haute
saison et puis il bénéfira des prix
minimum il y a toujours des prix bas et
des prio et donc on peut atteindre
jusqu'à 200 euros d'économie sur
certains billets par exemple on a
regardé à la Pointe-à-Pitre
dans votre question j'entends qu'est-ce
qu'on peut aménager le système européen
comment fonctionne une système européen
des obligations de service public
encoche tout réglementation fixée entre
deux points situés à l'intérieur du
territoire de l'Union Européenne est une
encoche au marché intérieur par
hypothèse puisque autrement il serait
libre donc si on fait une encoche on a
besoin de le signaler à tous les autres
États membres excusez-nous on va avoir
besoin de faire quelque chose de spécial
sur Paris entre Paris et Aurillac par
exemple
ça s'appelle une question de service
public ces obligations services ici il y
en a deux trois types soit elles sont
ouvertes c'est ce qui se passe sur les
dômes actuellement on a des règles
simples qui s'appliquent à tous les vols
qui sont gérables par tout le monde de
façon donc celui qui se présente sur la
réunion doit offrir des réductions pour
les enfants de moins de 2 ans 12 ans et
18 ans et bien mettre un accès
prioritaire à ceux qui ont
des sujets obsèques ou de rapatriement
très bien
comme je l'expliquais c'est pris en
compte partout c'est se reporter sur le
prix des autres passagers deuxième
hypothèse qui n'a jamais été utilisée
créer une OSP fermée non financé
autrement dit on crée un on crée un
régime qui est monopolistique on crée un
monopole
et on ne finance pas on ne l'a jamais
fait parce que on est jamais retrouvé
dans la situation où ça ça venait ça
venait bien et c'est en fait jamais été
pratiqué en Europe c'est c'est peut-être
que l'argumentation sur ce point était
mal construite je suis pas certain que
la système de monopole nous apporte
quelque chose de nouveau par rapport à
ce qu'on cherche parce que on va se
retrouver avec quelqu'un qui va tarifer
comme il veut troisième hypothèse créer
un créer une ESP financée
financier nécessite qu'il y ait derrière
l'OSP l'obligation de service public une
délégation de service public donc un
marché qui est un appel à candidature
pour qu'un marché un appel à candidature
il y a un seul gagnant donc on revient
dans le système du monopole donc on perd
la force du système qu'on avait au début
tout ça pour le financer de faire
financer par les pouvoirs publics par le
contribuable donc il y a un
problématique de logique si on crée des
ESP pour faire baisser les tarifs ça va
coûter à mon avis très très cher et on
va se retrouver avec des monopoles qu'on
va devoir gérer sans compter le coût
administratif et le bureaucratie qui va
avec donc le
[Musique]
je n'ai pas
je ne peux pas vous répondre que un
système d'osp fonctionne mieux d'après
l'expérience que nous avons sur des
segments plus petits Paris Aurillac
c'est c'est probablement 30 fois moins
de passagers que Paris La Réunion c'est
probablement
20 fois moins de kilomètres que Paris La
Réunion et ça coûte déjà très cher
si vous me permettez sur sur ce sujet
j'entends les différents hypothèses que
vous évoquez le directeur le PDG de
d'Air France KLM a déclaré récemment
qu'il y avait trop de compagnies
aériennes en outre-mer
ça présuppose quand même que sans le
dire comme ça c'est que il en appelle
quasiment un monopole ou à une fusion
une consolidation de certaines
entreprises est-ce que vous vous
observez un mouvement dans ce sens en
outre-mer et ce que vous pensez que les
entreprises sont relativement
solides pour rester propre sans se
regroupe et par exemple
monsieur ben Smith a quelque chose de
schumpeterien il veut recréer le
monopole lorsque il y en a pas c'est
normal il est chef d'entreprise il y a
un dilemme évident en fait plus
sérieusement entre
l'intérêt de la concurrence qui fait
baisser les tarifs c'est pas c'est pas
juste les DOM c'est c'est Paris Rome
c'est Paris Lisbonne c'est partout tout
le monde en profite d'une part et
d'autre part la nécessité d'avoir des
transporteurs en bonne santé financière
ce qui nécessite un minimum de
consolidation
et ce n'est pas à l'administration de se
prononcer sur les mouvements
capitalistiques possibles
éventuel mon avis toutefois c'est que
oui un tout petit peu de consolidation
ne serait pas une mauvaise chose pour
renforcer les entreprises on est arrivé
parfois à des quand on a eu jusqu'à cinq
transporteurs sur Paris La Réunion
on atteint des chiffres extrêmes dans le
marché intérieur européen de l'aviation
qui sont atteints nulle part ailleurs et
naturellement il y en a une des cinq qui
s'est cassé la figure c'est très élevé
et quatre compagnies sur une liaison
surtout très longue courrier c'est très
très élevé
donc si la question est de savoir si une
consolidation est souhaitable
si elle se passe dans de bonnes
conditions si les acteurs privés sont
d'accord si ça produit du fruit oui sans
doute nous n'avons pas en France mais
j'ai mes cartes un peu du dossier nous
n'avons pas en France une Virgin
Atlantique à la française si vous voulez
nous avons pas le grand acteur long
courrier de deuxième rang qu'on les
Anglais
et peut-être dans un univers
concurrentiel ça serait bien d'avoir pas
seulement Air France et je parle pas
seulement de les DOM et de toutes les
liaisons en général voilà c'est un avis
un peu personnel sur le sujet
une question sur la continuité
territoriale funéraire parce que je
crois qu'on l'avait évoqué quand on a
auditionné la DOM
et Catherine et Guillaume vous me
corrigerez le cas échéant vous avez fait
état monsieur de d'une utilisation
finalement relativement modeste au
regard de l'enveloppe global de la
continuité territoriale je crois que
c'est 130 000 euros a priori des ce qui
a été et un des points que qu'on avait
évoqué c'était les modalités de
déblocage en fait de cette continuité
territoriale en gros si j'ai bien
compris ils vont corriger il faut
d'abord que les gens avancent les frais
funéraires puis après se fasse
rembourser ce qui pose des difficultés
dans la plupart des cas puisque les gens
n'ont pas forcément justement la
capacité des avancées pour ensuite les
sollicités et donc la question qu'on
s'est posée à un moment donné pendant
l'audition c'est est-ce que une révision
ou un conventionnement et des
collectivités pour avoir justement un
relais sur cet aspect là des choses pour
être pour être étudié ou une
modification tout simplement des règles
de mobilisation de ces crédits est-ce
que c'est pas justement le
fonctionnement actuel qui empêche un
certain nombre de familles je me retiens
par Catherine parce que je crois
Catherine c'est toi qui avait posé la
question puisque tu avais été confronté
un certain nombre de casses en
territoire mais peut-être tu peux
prendre le relais et me et me compléter
si jamais je n'ai pas tout dit sur ce
sujet
oui président absolument il y a c'est
une complexité extraordinaire que j'ai
envie de dire
entre la porte de le montant apporté et
la complexité administrative souvent les
familles abandonnent la deuxième chose
c'est ce plafond de conditions de
ressources qui est pour moi inacceptable
totalement inacceptable quand on sait en
plus que pour un territoire comme la
cause qui en France comme nous il n'y a
pas de ressources quand on me parle de
dispositifs vectueux de médian de
revenus
on considère donc qu'avec un plafond de
ally j'arrondis 12000 euros on s'adresse
à un public
ciblé dans des pays où les taux de
pauvreté sont très importants ou
lorsqu'on expliqua on est deux riches
pauvres parce qu'il faut savoir que les
surcos
par exemple sur l'alimentation
approche et dépasse les 40%
supplémentaires
j'avoue que
voilà donc la sous-consommation de
certaines nombre de lignes dont celle du
funéraire sont liés à des complexités
administratives je l'ai moi-même
expérimenté pour certaines nombre de
familles
tout en annonçant mon nom qui j'étais
etc je l'ai laissé tomber j'ai laissé
tomber
le funéraire de mon itinéraire
il faut que la famille des caisses c'est
un remboursement
auprès un déplacement de corps comme ça
peut coûter entre 4 et 5000 euros on
donne 1000 euros et en plus c'est un
remboursement donc les gens laissent
tomber et on voit bien que les taux de
consommation sur ces lignes là sont très
faibles je me permets d'enchaîner
rapidement président sur tout ce qui est
assez spécifique concernant les sportifs
et les artistes là aussi les dossiers
sont individuels autrement dit vous
déplacez une équipe de foot où il y a 15
personnes avec le staff compris chaque
personne doit avoir un dossier
individuel
avec condition de ressources
donc ça veut dire que les dirigeants
sportifs au milieu de tout ce qu'ils
font déjà bénévolement doivent
questionner les parents leur demander
leurs avis d'imposition etc etc ce n'est
pas tenable
on dirait que il y a des dispositifs qui
sont mis en place qui sont justement
fait pour qu'on ne consomme pas là aux
gens on le dit pas mais c'est tout comme
et on a rencontré des dirigeants
sportifs par exemple à Marie-Galante qui
se déplace chaque semaine sur entre
guillemets le continent Guadeloupe et
qui ont préféré passer des partenariats
de mécénat avec des transporteurs parce
que la cité spécifique et inatteignable
inatteignable
individualisation des LED et non pas à
l'équipe mais à l'aide et puis ce fameux
ces fameux plafonds ressources ou aller
12000 euros vous divisez pas 12 je vous
laisse voir ce que ça fait pas moi c'est
juste alors on s'est trouvé dans des
situations où les gens dépassaient
parfois de 4 euros le plafond de
ressources et voyez l'autre aussi rejeté
au grand dames des gens de la dame qu'on
a trouvé assez triste
de nous annoncer ça 4 euros il dépasse
ils n'ont pas droit autrement dit ils
sont tombés dans la catégorie de riches
avec 4 euros supplémentaires divisé
12000 par 12 c'est simple ça fait 1000
euros par mois quoi avec des prix
d'alimentation supérieure de 38%
la cause n'a pas de condition de
ressources donc j'ai entendu parler du
mauvais oxyeux elle est où la vertu elle
est où
si vous voulez répondre après ce
plaidoyer merci Catherine d'avoir
complété mes propos
peut-être voilà on commence on commence
on va commencer par le la fin pour
remonter pour remonter dans dans vos
questions madame la sénatrice sur un
autre voilà mon collègue va
effectivement va aborder un autre
dispositif qui est très qui est très qui
était qui est peut-être sans doute
beaucoup mieux orienté pour les les
mieux adaptés pardon pour les publics
notamment sportifs juste un mot pour
dire que voilà nous nous rejoignons sur
le aussi sur le défaut de communication
de de la Dom en tout cas ça va partir
aussi du projet la Dom 2024 de renforcer
sa communication d'avoir des sites
internet beaucoup plus clair beaucoup
plus étoffés d'avoir aussi bien sûr des
équipes aussi plus proactives sur ce sur
ce volet communication j'ai oublié de
l'indiquer tout à l'heure donc
effectivement il faudra communiquer sur
l'ensemble des dispositifs je pense ceux
de la DOM et ceux qui pourraient aussi
très approprié comme celui que va
évoquer mon collègue
oui
simplement oui il existe aussi sur le
programme 123 un dispositif qui
s'appelle le fond des changes abus
éducatif sportif et culturel donc le
faitex
qui permet pour le coup qui permet pour
le coup de d'apporter une réponse alors
certainement partielle parce que bon le
montant c'est 2 millions d'euros sur
l'ensemble des territoires mais qui
apporte quand même une une réponse à
cette question de du traitement
individuel des sportifs dont il s'agit
de déplacer une équipe c'est aussi un
outil qui peut être mobilisé alors c'est
pas un outil qui est aujourd'hui opéré
par la Dom c'est quelque chose qui est
traité par les préfectures mais c'est
quelque chose qui est pour le coup assez
bien utilisé année après année
voilà sinon moi je
suis très honnêtement sur la continuité
funéraire pour y revenir j'ai donné les
chiffres tout à l'heure factuellement
c'est effectivement sous consommé il y a
moi je le crois volontiers
des problèmes peut-être de connaissances
des dispositifs il y a aussi il faut le
regarder droit en face le fait que
dépenser de l'argent public c'est c'est
jamais simple il y a forcément des
règles puisqu'il s'agit d'argent public
et c'est vrai que ça s'emboîte assez mal
avec l'urgence et la détresse d'une
famille qui est confrontée à un décès
c'est c'est il faut qu'on regarde les
les choses de cette manière là aussi et
il faut qu'on faut qu'on voit comment
quel est le vecteur le plus adapté
qu'est-ce qu'on peut imaginer comme
comme solution véritablement pérante
c'est c'est il y a forcément une
complexité dès lors qu'on est avec de
l'argent public c'est c'est regrettable
mais c'est aussi une réalité
peut-être que oui si vous
on apportera aussi peut-être quelques
compléments peut-être sur les modalités
de d'utilisation de cette de cette aide
cette aide funéraire si vous le
souhaitez mais je
si vous avez peut-être
oui bonjour à tous non je secouais la
tête parce que bon
c'est vrai que les demandes doivent être
faites à la préfecture d'accord mais
comme la rappeler la collègue ça coûte
très très cher ça c'est une goutte d'eau
en fait et moi je pense que il faudrait
peut-être réfléchir à une plus plus
forte
un plus formant parce que enfin moi je
suis guyanaise moi je peux vous en
parler quand il y a un décès à l'hôpital
Lariboisière je peux vous dire que les
familles ne cessent d'appeler les élus
pour essayer justement de les
accompagner de les aider alors
quelquefois ça dans notre poche quand
vraiment la famille veut inhumer son
parent à Cayenne vous je sais pas si
vous comprenez ce que je veux dire donc
c'est très très cher et justement je
voulais vous remercier pour pour vos
réponses parce que en fait vous
démontrez encore aujourd'hui l'inégalité
de traitement de considération entre les
Français de l'hexagone et les Français
ultramarins je suis désolé je dis pas
que c'est de votre faute mais les
réponses que vous nous avez apportées ne
font que démontrer cette inégalité entre
les Français alors moi je voulais poser
une question à la DGAC puisque vous mes
collègues
Catherine et Guillaume vous ont dit tout
à l'heure que nous sommes rendus à Marie
pasula bon je suis guyanaise donc je
connaissais la problématique des de mes
compatriotes mais ils ont pu découvrir
en tout cas dans quelles conditions les
passagers sont transportés entre Cayenne
et Maripasoula donc c'est quand même
plus de 20000 personnes par an et ce
n'est pas un cas isolé selon
erguyan puisque nous avons rencontré le
directeur de la Guyane la Guyane serait
le seul département d'outre-mer où les
aéroports ne sont pas aux normes
européennes je sais que la gestion des
aérodromes incombe à la collectivité
territoriale mais elle peut pas tout
faire seule donc je voulais vous
demander qu'est-ce que vous comptez
faire bien entendu en partenariat avec
la CTG pour permettre au guyanais de
voyager dans de meilleures conditions
lorsque vous devez savoir que les
guyanais ont décidé en tout cas de se
prendre en charge puisque il y a un
collectif qui travaille sur les routes
de désenclavesment parce que quand on
met la panne des avions quelquefois qui
dure 15 jours donc nous compatriotes de
Marie pasula ne peuvent pas venir se
soigner à Cayenne ne peuvent pas venir
voir un parent malade à Cayenne sinon
prendre la pirogue sur 48 heures en 48
heures donc vous imaginez bien que c'est
compliqué j'ai une deuxième question je
souhaite pas ici rappeler la différence
de traitement entre la Corse et les
départements d'outre-mer en matière de
continuité territoriale d'autres le font
régulièrement toutefois j'ai beaucoup de
mal à comprendre comment l'État
n'apporte que 1 million cinq d'euros
face aux 8 millions 500 € de la
collectivité territoriale de Guyane dans
le cadre de cette DSP d'un montant de 10
millions d'euros
et si ma mémoire me fait pas défaut la
participation de l'État se limite à deux
lignes sur 4 c'est Cayenne marie-pasoula
alors qu'il existe Cayenne grand-senty
et Cayenne Saint-Laurent quels sont les
freins à une participation plus
importante de l'État et pour finir la
collectivités territoriale et la
compagnie Air Guyane rencontrent
régulièrement les associations des
usagers dans le but de travailler sur
l'amélioration du service rendu au
public la DGAC qui au nom de l'État est
signataire de la DSP ne si jamais dans
ses réunions
pensez-vous qu'il y a quelque chose à
améliorer à votre niveau voilà les trois
questions que je voulais poser à la DGAC
il y en a encore beaucoup d'autres mais
je m'abstiendrai de poursuivre il y aura
certainement une autre fois merci
beaucoup monsieur vivez
merci de ces questions donc je vous
rejoins sur le défaut de service partiel
ou régulier en tout cas de la société
Air Guyane
qui est le même membre du groupe Caire
enfin la hervian et Antilles étant la
même entreprise et la même le même
certificat de transporterait rien nous
avons constaté comme vous des
défaillances dans le service promis au
titre de la DSP qu'elle a signé
elle encoura des pénalités pour ça les
pénalités sont rédigées
procès-verbaux sont rédigés par les
régions Guyane nous sommes mains dans la
main avec la les services de la Région
pour leur les aider à rédiger
correctement ce qu'il faut comme
pénalité et pas faire d'erreur
juridiques parce que on est en face de
nous des acteurs qui sont malins aussi
et donc on est là dans ma main dans la
main éventuellement s'il faut pour pour
travailler à une
liaison supplémentaire par jour sur Mary
pasoula on y a travaillé avec le
président de la région
et donc
ça c'est c'est tout à fait vu
ce sont des appels d'offres si au
prochain appel d'offres il y a un autre
transporteur qui se présente je
conseille à la région de regarder ce
qu'elle préférable mais c'est vrai que
on peut faire mieux franchement au
niveau des pistes je suis mal placé en
tant que ce vecteur de service céréales
j'aurais besoin de ma collègue sous
directrice des aéroports mais ce que je
sais c'est que évidemment ce sont des
pistes très particulières il y a des
mêmes besoins d'avion particulier pour
atterrir en Guyane sur des pistons
latérites il faut typiquement des des
avions check LED 410 ou des twinteurs
enfin il y a pas beaucoup d'avions qui
peuvent s'opposer sur une piste en
latérite donc il faut à ce moment-là
construire une piste en dur la piste
Maripasoula en dur vous la savez mieux
que moi eu des soucis les travaux c'est
un espèce de mauvais feuilleton qui se
passe pas bien on est là pour aider la
région dans ces travaux et pour pour
l'assister mais effectivement il y a un
souci de piste aussi à certains endroits
mais vous posez une question sur la
participation financière de l'État qui
est en effet 1,5 millions d'euros par an
cette participation financière
est stable c'est-à-dire que elle était
la même avant lorsqu'il y avait le
système des aides au passagers et c'est
la raison pour laquelle sous le contrôle
les trois de nos collègues de ministère
des Finances nous avons maintenu cette
participation
au niveau où elle était dans le nouveau
système juridique de la DSP tout
simplement voilà siéger aux réunions de
CGO réunion je peux effectivement en
parler aux mes collègues de la Direction
Territoriale
anti Guyane parce que c'est une seule
direction territoriale pour nous à
l'aviation voir comment il pourrait se
déplacer plus souvent être mieux présent
aux réunions comme vous l'avez demandé
est-ce que j'ai oublié quelque chose
madame
et je pense qu'on a été coupé dans notre
élan sur la continuité territoriale
funéraire puisque j'avais suggéré
peut-être poser la question de savoir si
le dispositif pouvait évoluer soit en
partenariat avec les collectivités
soi-même une révision des conditions
d'accès au dispositif
Immo peut-être technique je me permets
de passer la parole peut-être à notre
collègue pour expliquer un petit peu
aujourd'hui le dispositif et pour vous
dire que encore une fois constamment
nous essayons d'adapter les dispositifs
aux besoins à la réalité et bien sûr
l'objectif n'est absolument pas de faire
en sorte que le que les dispositifs ne
soient pas utilisés feront passe
énormément de temps nous-mêmes sur pour
essayer d'améliorer les choses il y a eu
encore une fois beaucoup d'amélioration
sur la continuité funéraire qui ont été
initiés en 2021 donc on est dans un
dispositif qui est bien sûr en constante
amélioration donc je vais passer là
peut-être la parole juste pour une
courte description courte très courte
description de dispositif et voir si
effectivement on peut continuer à
améliorer améliorer les choses alors
quand on parle de continuité funéraire
en fait
juridiquement ça n'a pas vraiment
d'existence juridiquement ce sont deux
choses différentes
il y a
l'aide à la continuité territoriale
utilisée en vue dans un avec un motif
funéraire
l'aide à la continuité territoriale
donc peut-être utilisé pour
se rendre à des obsèques et là c'est
possible dans les deux sens pour un
résident de métropole qui a des obsèques
en outre-mer ou pour un résident
d'outre-mer qui a des obsèques en
métropole
et ça a été élargi en 2021
à une la possibilité de prendre donc
c'est assez T pour une dernière visite
un parent
qui donc serait en fin de vie
ça a été aussi ouvert
c'était c'était limité aux parents aux
parents de premier degré au premier
degré ça a été ouvert aux frères et
sœurs
et l'autre pan de ce qu'on appelle la
continuité funéraire c'est le transport
de corps
sur
le transport de corps
c'est une aide qui peut être prise à
défaut
d'assurance
contractée par
le défunt contracté par la famille
pour pour couvrir ce risque parce que
l'idée n'était pas de remplacer les
services assurantiels
donc c'est s'il y a un accident
et voilà
ça couvre uniquement les frais de
transport aérien alors quand il y a un
transport de corps il y a effectivement
de nombreux frais qui s'additionnent
mais le la continuité territoriale
transport de corps couvre uniquement le
transport le segment transport aérien
alors en effet ces plafonnés ces
plafonnés pour un transport entre la
métropole et les Antilles et plafonner à
ses 50% du du
coût du transport aérien ces plafonné à
1000 euros c'est plafonniers en fonction
du des distances il y a trois tranches
de distance
voilà
et c'est seulement pour
permettre aux disons faire en sorte que
le défunt retourne dans sa collectivité
de résidence si c'est un défunt si si le
défunt habitait en métropole était
résident de métropole installé depuis
des années en métropole il devient
résident métropolitain et il ne peut la
famille peut pas faire valoir qu'il est
dans la dans le cadre actuel de la
réglementation la famine ne peut pas
faire valoir qu'il est résident
d'outre-mer et donc c'est réservé aux
transports des défunts vers leur
territoire de résidence
et par rapport au prix financement en
fait dans les deux cas l'aide à la
continuité territoriale
pour obsèques pour dernière visite ou
pour le transport de corps
le préfet le préfinancement c'est pas
une obligation si on a si la personne si
le demandeur de l'aide à le temps devant
lui de demander l'aide et d'obtenir et
d'obtenir le bon
l'accord la décision administrative
favorable et bien il n'est pas obligé de
préfinancer mais en général tout se fait
dans dans l'urgence et c'est voilà c'est
pour cela que
a été ouverte la possibilité pour le
bénéficiaire de prêt financer
je ne sais pas s'il y a d'autres
questions pardon de nos rapporteurs ou
de nos collègues
Catherine Catherine peut-être non
président comment va je suppose vers la
conclusion je n'ai pas eu de réponse de
la sécurité sociale quant à la prise en
charge de ce qu'ils ont appelé je
reprends mes notes pour être très
précise dans le lexique ce qu'ils ont
appelé l'hébergement temporaire non
médicalisé quite de la Guadeloupe 8 de
la Guyane en tout cas lors de nos
déplacements nous avons été confrontés à
des situations que j'ai décrite tout à
l'heure exemple en Guadeloupe exemple en
Guyane donc quitter dispositifs à mettre
en place pour permettre un meilleur
accueil
[Musique]
hors de chez eux les personnes qui sont
déplacement temporaire pour des raisons
de santé
visiblement ça relève sa relève donc de
la sécurité sociale et d'ailleurs
interpellé le directeur du port de
Pointe-à-Pitre sur cette question
ça c'est une question sur laquelle sauf
étouffe je n'ai pas eu de réponse de la
sécurité sociale et puis je vais
terminer sur une une
un sentiment
j'ai l'impression que l'ambition elle
est on le dira de toute façon au niveau
politique après la livraison de notre
rapport vous êtes des fonctionné donc
tout respectons votre votre réserve et
le fait que vous êtes attaché à
l'application des directives politiques
que vous avez nous sommes aussi des
politiques donc notre rôle aussi est
d'influencer et de conduire le
changement
j'ai l'impression d'une ambition qui est
vraiment au rat des pâquerettes
concernant ces c'est
territoire là vraiment au ras des pas
chrétiens j'ai souri plusieurs fois
quand j'ai entendu certains mots
j'ai souri plusieurs fois le fEBEX
c'est la jungle pour l'obtenir c'est pas
à moi seulement qui le dit ce sont les
opérateurs sur le terrain et on enverra
encore dans les deux ou trois auditions
qui nous restent à faire même les
services de l'État nous disent que c'est
la jungle pour la voir
bon alors quand on dit assez bien
consommé j'ai noté le mot qu'est-ce
qu'on appelle assez bien consommé
j'ai déjà parlé de la partie condition
de ressources cette condition de
ressources j'ose le mot c'est une honte
est une honte
concernant ce qui se passe encore
la France c'est comme nous et je mets
envie de dire que de protéger graphique
la cause est aussi outreme puisqu'il
faut traverser la comme nous comme nous
vous avez vu et tenter de comparer de
temps en temps ce qui se passe encore et
100% payé par l'État et ce qui se passe
dans nos dans nos pays
j'irai plus loin même en disant qu'il
est anormal
anormal si on lit le code des transports
qu'il y ait autant d'argent qui reste
sur le dos de la collectivité par
exemple de Guyane
la France donne l'état donne des
cacahuètes
des cacahuètes même pas vin pour ça
. alors que si je lis le code des
transports je lis tout simplement je
suis pas une juriste mais je sais au
moins lire en code c'est une compétence
qui relèverait de l'État les corps sont
très bien compris et lorsque nous avons
dictionné la cause ici j'ai posé la
question à la collègue de cause la
collègue élue de cause qu'est-ce qui
restait sur les bras de la collectivité
de cause pour assurer ses plus de 220
millions pour 350 000 habitants de
continuité territoriale marchandise et
passager elle m'a dit rien
100% état y compris les frais de
fonctionnement
je trouve aussi anormal que la Dom soit
dans un tel état de de
aller
d'antiquités concernant le traitement
des dossiers c'est de l'Antiquité
on est encore au stade de remettre aux
gens un bon papier qui vont porter dans
une agence de voyage aux compagnies
aériennes sont de traitement qu'il
aurait demandé qui n'est pas compensé
aucune aide salon
pour compliquer ces dimanches là si je
compare avec l'autre les collectivités
au moins qui collationne des petits
papiers avec des tampons comme autour de
ma grand-mère au guichet de la poste
quand est-ce que ça va évoluer ça tous
ces éléments là sont pas de nature à
favoriser l'accès à la continuité
territoriale
on est dans de la sous-consommation ça
devrait interpoler la Domme dégage un
accident de plus de 2 millions d'euros
sur l'exercice précédent un excédent il
devrait pas avoir d'excédent donc
j'invite les autres à avoir des
évaluations
objectives lucide évaluer dans nos pays
c'est souvent l'impression qu'on vous
contrôle qui a de l'acquisition non
évaluer ces données du sens à une
volonté du gouvernement qui est
d'affirmer la différenciation on le dit
on le répète tous les matins mais qu'en
est-il de l'application
réelle de cette volonté de traitement de
la différenciation et je suis
extrêmement heureuse d'être au coeur de
cette mission mais vous pouvez pas
imaginer comment je suis heureuse
c'est un bonheur pour moi parce que je
peux toucher depuis maintenant début
janvier ce que c'est que la
différenciation justement dans le
traitement dans le traitement entre
Français de l'hexagone et le français
d'ailleurs je la touche du doigt je la
vois elle est flagrante donc si on a
cette ambition politique portée qui est
de dire que il y a des gens là-bas il y
a des gens là-bas qui sont français sur
des territoires auxquels on dit tenir
puisqu'on dit tout le temps que le
soleil ne secoue jamais en France
n'est-ce pas grâce à nous qu'en est-il
d'une véritable politique de continuité
territoriale portée dans ses territoires
là il ne laisse pas autant de changes
mentales politiques financier logistique
sur le dos des collectivités
et pour revenir et pour conclure
j'attends pointer du doigt et en Guyane
certainement ils sont pas parfaits ils
sont sur un créneau extrêmement
compliqué sur la créneau sur lequel
personne ne viendra généralement ils
sont les seuls à soumissionner quand il
y a des DSP à venir
j'entends parler déjà de ils sont malins
il y a déjà une connotation il y a des
pénalités qui vont être appliquées on a
écouté en Guyane pendant deux heures
deux heures je ne crois pas que Monsieur
Manon soit quelqu'un de malhonnête ce
martiniquais et pris de sa région je ne
le crois pas malhonnête quand il nous
fait état de certains noms de ces
difficultés les difficultés pour
atterrir les difficultés de non
équipement des aéroports en outil de de
de
d'atterrissage par exemple pour parfois
ils sont obligés de faire demi-tour à
Maliba sous la parce qu'ils ne peut pas
atterrir d'une piste qui n'arrête pas de
marcher alors que ça relève de la
compétence de l'État
non je veux bien qu'on fasse porter la
chance ou X ou Y et tout mais je crois
que je conclus dessus il y a une remise
en cause collective
le rapport que nous allons livrer dans
quelques jours d'ici la fin du mois va
être un excellent outil pour vous pour
vous aider à se profond travail
on ne le prend pas pour de l'Inquisition
ni un procès fait à la continuité
territoriale on le prend pour un apport
qui devrait décisif dans vos futurs
révolutions en matière de continuité
territoriale il faut que ça se fasse
avec de l'ambition l'ambition n'est pas
seulement que financier là je reviens
pas dessus c'est comme ce million contre
220 millions allez allez peu mieux fait
mais j'ai envie de dire que ne serait-ce
que dans le service rendu dans les
formations portées dans la lisibilité
des politiques publiques dans
l'adaptation technique des politiques
publiques ce rapport va vous aider donc
je vous demande de l'attendre avant de
partir sur la dôme 2024 attendez le nous
allons être pour vous d'excellents
partenaires qui vont vous dire le regard
leur vérité parce que nous vivons dans
ces territoires là vous vous passez nous
nous vivons et nous sommes du 1er
janvier au 31 décembre
qui régulièrement viennent nous
témoigner de leur mécontentement donc ce
rapport va être pour vous quelque chose
on va vous le livrer gratuitement
gratuitement ça va être des heures
d'énergie pas ôté par les élus mais
aussi les fonctionnaires de la
délégation que je remercie merci pour
l'excellence de l'autre à vous
d'accompagnement de rédaction etc bravo
la délégation merci président mais
attendez ce rapport il vous dira des
choses faites tomber vos a prioris
faites tomber plein de choses et surtout
pour nos pays ayons
effectivement de l'ambition on le dira
aux politiques on le dit au ministre on
le dira même plus loin moi je compte
aller aller sensibiliser le président de
la République sur ces données là parce
qu'il s'agit de de
direction politique qui sont extrêmement
importantes on ira jusqu'à la porte de
l'Élysée pour lui dire cette rupture
mais il faudra aussi que dans le
déroulement vous ayez cette ce regard
objectif
ambitieux de service qui doivent être
porter à une population qui le mérite
parce qu'elle est française parce
qu'elle a des doigts parce qu'elle a
aussi des besoins qui sont certainement
plus importants en matière de santé de
déplacement etc etc c'est ce que je
voulais vous dire en conclusion et je
vous le dis avec beaucoup de sincérité
avec beaucoup d'émotion parce que je vis
cette mission avec mon coeur
mon cœur de martiniquaise donc membre de
ce qu'on appelle l'outre-mer au milieu
de toutes nos vicissitudes que nous
vivons quotidien mettez ce mot ambition
en lettres d'eau au dessus de vos
bureaux c'est ça qui devra pas ôter la
révolution attendue de la DOM et de la
continuité territoriale 2024 c'est
demain la livraison de notre rapport
j'ai presque envie de dire en terme
relatif de délai c'est tout à l'heure
attendez-nous et faites de ce rapport un
outil majeur dans la transformation de
la continuité territoriale dans la vie
d'outre-mer je vous remercie
quand la personne peut être sauvée à
Cayenne mais il y a pas de vol la nuit
on fait quoi on est voué à mourir je
sais que c'est un problème pour vous
enfin comme disait ma collègue Catherine
Concorde c'est encore une problématique
que je vous soumets c'est compliqué je
suis sûr que parmi vous vous n'êtes
jamais venu en Guyane donc vous
connaissez pas la Guyane vous pouvez pas
connaître les réalités donc c'est juste
un plus que je vous apporte si vous
n'avez pas la réponse messieurs je ne
vous en voudrais pas mais je veux vous
sensibiliser parce que nous sommes tous
des Français des humains et on a tous
envie de vivre et quand on voit cette
situation ça nous fait mal au cœur nous
les politiciens parce que bon on est
cette défendre mais comme disait
Catherine tout à l'heure il faut être
ambitieux et je suis je suis comme toi
Catherine je suis contente de participer
à cette mission continuité territoriale
parce que ça fait trop longtemps qu'on
en souffre et si aujourd'hui le rapport
des deux rapporteurs peuvent vous
éclairer et puis que vous vous utilisiez
comme base je serais vraiment très très
heureuse en tout cas ça c'est une
problématique que je voulais vous
soumettre mais je comprendrais si vous
n'avez pas la réponse parce que nous on
l'a pas nous on l'a pas on n'a pas les
moyens qu'il faut et ça fait mal ça fait
mal de savoir que quelqu'un aurait été
en France hexagonale on aurait pu le
transporter dans un hôpital pour le
sauver alors que pour l'aiguillages
c'est pas possible en tout cas les
Guyanais de l'intérieur
alors on vérifiera mais c'est juste des
évaces urgentes sur régulation CMU etc
elles peuvent se tenir la nuit comme le
jour s'il y a l'équipe disponible s'il y
a un besoin
urgent de voilà et un vecteur disponible
enfin rien n'empêche que ça se produise
pas donc avec les lignes commerciales
mais avec un moyen dédié et là il y a
énormément de situations différentes
mais alors c'est de l'intérieur vers la
capitale mais après si la capitale ne
peut pas c'est vrai qu'on travaille sur
un centre hospitalier
universitaire régional mais si la
capitale ne peut pas en fait quoi donc
ça veut dire que là encore il faut qu'on
attende la journée parce que qui qui
transportera ce malade en France
hexagonale
juste lui quoi voilà
ça peut se faire vers la métropole ça
peut se faire aussi au niveau zonal ça a
été le cas pendant le covid il y a
énormément de de situation différente
mais là aussi c'est toute une logistique
on mettra plus d'éléments sur ce sujet
de la nuit si vous le souhaitez dans
dans le questionnaire
donc au-delà des aspects politiques
évidemment pour lesquels on vous demande
pas de prendre position parce que c'est
au ministre de le faire et pas et pas à
vous en l'occurrence il y avait je pense
dans l'intervention Catherine Cancun des
questions tout au début de
l'intervention qui peut-être pouvait
apporter faire l'objet de réponse plus
technique me semble-t-il un Katrina
oui en effet sur ce qu'on appelle bébé
je pourrais non médicalisé exemple
Guyane exemple
pour répondre à la sénatrice à vous
remarquer et interrogations
ce dispositif d'hébergement temporaire
non médicalisé qu'on appelle aussi hôtel
hospitalier parti du nouveau volonté
déjà du gouvernement de ce qu'on appelle
l'élargissement du panier de soins dont
la vocation première est de faciliter
l'accès aux soins j'ai cité
l'hébergement temporairement médicalisé
mais on peut aussi citer aussi citer
engagement maternité qui est un
dispositif du même
de même nature et qui vise les femmes
enceintes et parturientes qui sont à
plus de 45 minutes d'une maternité et
qui est ce même sur le même principe
pendant que financement assurance
maladie un dispositif récent qui a été
généralisé alors en pleine période de
crise sanitaire qui est pas forcément la
plus favorable à une comment dire une
bonne condition de généralisation
et avec un constat en 2021 qui a été
fait d'un déploiement encore trop
insatisfaisant du dispositif mais parce
que mais parce que récent et pas dans
les meilleures conditions je
[Musique]
peut-être de construire sur le site ce
qu'on appelle donc un hôtel hospitalier
un hébergement temporaire non médicalisé
il était prévu donc un financement
incitatif à ce dispositif un paiement un
paiement à la limite qui devait
s'interrompre à la fin de l'année 2000
je crois 22 qu'il a été prévu de
reconduire parce que justement ce
déploiement était encore trop
insatisfaisant et que l'évaluation qui
était prévue parce que le dispositif
même généralisé doit être évalué ne peut
pas se faire sur ce niveau je disais
insatisfait enfin comment dire incomplet
inégalement réparti de déploiement donc
du coup les services du ministères
accompagnent et vont encourager à
nouveau les établissements les ARS à
développer encore plus pour à nouveau
réévaluer d'ici un an un an et demi le
dispositif en faisant enfin et en
faisant l'hypothèse qu'il je disais
trouvera ce déployer dans les
territoires d'outre-mer où selon nous il
a toute sa place
écoutez je propose qu'on puisse arrêter
là vous voulez peut-être apporter des
éléments de réponse
je voulais juste faire un point sur
l'accord puisque on a on a cité ce l'île
de beauté à plusieurs reprises dans la
conversation et il y avait l'idée
derrière du tarif résident Corse qui
figurait dans votre questionnaire donc
j'ai apporté un premier élément de
réponse tout à l'heure en expliquant que
toute mesure d'obligation de service
public financé à mener nécessairement à
un monopole ce qui est le cas entre
Marseille d'une part Marseille Nice et
Paris d'une part et Ajaccio Figari et
Calvi et Bastia d'autre part ce qui fait
12 liaisons sous-osp financer par
l'Office des transports de Corse qui
fait un gros travail
donc j'ai expliqué ce premier point qui
était la créer un monopole en fait
financer c'est la première conséquence
de ce type de mesure et ensuite il faut
regarder l'efficacité du système aussi
c'est intéressant de regarder ce qui se
passe sur les liaisons qui ne sont pas
sous-espé je prends par exemple le
Strasbourg Ajaccio ou Nantes Bastia ce
genre de liaison il y en a beaucoup et
on a des transporteurs européens qui
font des vols low cost je puis dire
pour des prix qui sont les mêmes qui
sont même le 200 euros aller-retour Orly
Ajaccio vous allez trouver je suis allé
regarder récemment vous allez trouver
des des Strasbour Ajaccio je cite pas le
nom du transporteur mais pour pour un
mois avant à 80 euros donc ou 100 euros
donc ça fait d'aller retour ça fait 200
c'est pareil
beaucoup de coup pour les finances
publiques zéro donc il faut aussi bien
réfléchir avant de se lancer dans ce
type de dispositif voilà c'est c'est des
sujets complexes difficiles de tous les
côtés mais il y a aussi des la
microéconomie je me fais un peu le
porteur aujourd'hui merci
oui allez-y je vous en prie c'est
monsieur le Président si vous permettez
juste sur le calendrier pour pour
répondre à Madame machinatrice madame la
rapporteur monsieur le rapporteur
effectivement nous sommes aussi heureux
de prendre ce seront bien sûr heureux de
prendre connaissance de vous de vos
travaux bien entendu et sachant que
voilà l'idée était bien que
effectivement pour pour nous d'essayer
de de faire le maximum d'un point de vue
technique dans vos services bien sûr des
décisions politiques qui auront lieu
après sur sur cet aspect de renforcement
de l'ambition de la Dom qui qui vraiment
va amener un travail tous ces e-mails
pour essayer de renforcer son action
donc nous
ce message juste pour dire que le
ministère des Outre-mer est bien sûr au
service des outre-mer et bien sûr aucun
a priori dans aucun a priori et essaye
de renforcer au maximum ce dispositif
comme comme les autres donc votre votre
travaux seront à particulièrement lui
avec particulièrement d'attention et
bien sûr nous continuons les travaux
d'appui aussi à la Dom dans le cadre de
sa de sa réforme et donc nous essayons
de relever ce nous essaierons de relever
ce challenge de l'ambition voilà
merci je vous propose de d'arrêter cette
cette audition à ce stade et je vous
remercie vraiment pour toutes les
contributions que vous nous avez dont
vous nous avez déjà fait part par écrit
et celle que vous seriez amené à nous
faire par la suite de cette audition
pour enrichir les travaux de la
délégation merci et bonne fin de journée
à toutes et à tous